I will defeat this game if it's the last
thing I'll ever do this game is easy ok
if you haven't played this game it's a
piece of cake this cake is it's not a
very delicious cake but it's a cake that
needs to be eaten alive
first you got to make sure you go up
here right okay
all right slow down there cowboy we're
not speedrunning it now we got to get up
to the rink which you might think oh
that's impossible
it's actually super easy now this bit
you want to go out as far as possible
and you want to pendulum swing and that
actually makes the slide 20 times easier
a lot of people struggle on the slide
not this guy there's another one of
those where you just have to launch
yourself and right before you go you're
gonna die that's how it's done so what
you want to do is you want to grab the
hammer yeah
and you want to go down very slowly very
nice
oh god that's not slow Betty you're not
going too slow right now buddy
oh you oh no you I made a terrible oh
look at that oh look at that
you thought I made it they're above me
think a bit did you see now we're gonna
do the same trick as we have done before
now I've only oh my god okay we're just
gonna we're just gonna [ __ ] that's
what it means to peer back no that's you
thank you then you weep alone for the
sad old dingy can you be quiet
can I turn him off can I turn me enough
oh wow the game just became better
[Music]
hello what's up what's up
[ __ ] you
[Music]
what's up everybody it's your boy [ __ ]
oh god what have I done
ah look at that skillet look at that sky
back game journalist little 5000 right
there Power Move Power Move left and
right
hell yeah man you tellin it Felix
oh no what's good everybody eyes you boy
yeah it's you using macros the [ __ ]
excuse me the door is ringing
[Music]
I'm the best goddamn gamer on YouTube
lift me up like [ __ ] and damn it it's so
frustrating I have no control
just like waving my foot stuck on my
[ __ ] toes can you suck a dick my god
like oh my god no no I'm so [ __ ] oh
my god oh my god this stupid grumbling
little thing in the mouse and my god
okay right
how in the world do I get up from there
he doesn't [ __ ] going
[Music]
what
[Music]
no we do not go down there no we talked
about this oh my god it I'm sweating so
much this stupid guy no relax
new strat new strat new strat that will
pierce no no [ __ ] new strat what the
[ __ ] like launch yourself woman did I
just hear someone using microaggression
whoa whoa whoa
what just happened what just happened
how did I do that
oh my god oh my well mostly in the room
can I just sit here can I just sit here
[Music]
you know you know they tell you you hear
bells ringing before you die
I can't tell if it's real life or the
game at this point oh no no no no no we
fight back oh god oh my god
oh wow oh okay
okay we're on the toilet sitting on a
toilet
[Laughter]
Oh huh
shut up music
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now we go down there gays yeah
oh my motion Durrell everybody what the
heck is this my body is shaking
what what's up everybody
Oh what no no no no no you can't be
serious what happens down there do I
have to go up there if I fall what
happens if I fall down you're so mean
whoever made this Bennett you're so mean
let's just push away this orange go away
can we push this out a little bit well
no that's frozen okay oh wow
there's no checkpoints
there is no checkpoint
that's so mean hmm whoa Wow okay it's so
steep it's seriously so steep oh wow oh
wow look at that look at that everybody
it's your boy PewDiePie I'm gonna cry oh
my god it gets steeper it's just not
fair it's just not fair
oh my god it gets even worse oh my god
you know they tell you you hear bells
ringing before you die no
[Music]